all right let's get caught up about a
number of goings-on in the american
political world hillary clinton is never
running for president again this is what
she is now saying and this is
interesting because there has been
increasing speculation not only from
some on the left who are
sort of uh skeptical of the
establishment democratic party but also
for many on the right who seem convinced
that at some point hillary clinton will
return and 2024 will be a rematch
between trump and clinton
hillary clinton is now very directly
saying she is not running for president
again she was interviewed by nora
o'donnell she was asked the question
directly and then maybe more
interestingly she was asked well then
what about if trump runs in 2024
let's take a look at this this is pretty
interesting hillary clinton is on a new
campaign of sorts with her daughter
chelsea for a new apple tv plus
docu-series highlighting extraordinary
women it's called gutsy we sat down
exclusively with the former secretary
and asked her what's next
would you ever run for president again
no no but i'm going to do everything i
can to make sure that
we have a president who respects our
democracy and the rule of law and
upholds our institutions what if donald
trump runs again he should be soundly
defeated it should start in the
republican party grow a backbone stand
up to this guy and heaven forbid if he
gets the nomination he needs to be
defeated roundly and sent back to
mar-a-lago the florida mansion now in
the spotlight after an fbi
so she's being very clear here she's not
running for president again now those
who are committed to the idea of some
conspiracy to install hillary clinton or
whatever they will say that she still
might run but
i believe her it seems very clear that
she isn't running and i think that this
is correct i don't think that she should
run again she would have been a better
president than trump i voted for her but
i believe that the window has passed and
i think it's the same thing with bernie
sanders quite frankly even though i know
there are many in my audience who don't
like it when i say that and when i say
this i am not speaking
you know
i i want to remind everybody one of the
ways in which
i hope the left is different from the
right
is that we don't deify candidates
trump often will say i don't know that
joe biden has anybody running around
with a biden hat or a biden shirt or
whatever
yeah because on the left my desire is
that we see elected officials just as
people with whom we hopefully agree on
more than we disagree
and we vote for them and then we move on
with our lives in other words the right
has these cults of personality sometimes
the left does too
and sometimes when i say i think
bernie's time has passed
people will get very angry as with me
because they see bernie almost as as a
sort of deity i voted for bernie in the
primary and hillary ended up being the
nominee i voted for hillary in the
general but she lost i would vote for
either of them over trump or desantis or
whoever
but i think both of them
despite me voting for them
are now beyond running for president and
i mean listen maybe hillary should run
for special master and could review
those documents no i'm kidding but i
believe this is the right decision i
believe it is really you know it's been
said for a while now
really since obama it's i guess over a
while six years it's been said for a
period of time now
that overall the democratic party needs
to look younger in its ranks for
presidential candidates i think that
hillary recognizes that i think bernie
recognizes as well i don't think either
is going to run for the democratic
nomination in 2024 and there really are
lots of good people around and i've
talked about many of them and i would
like to see uh some some other new
people run and we'll have plenty of time
to talk about that
in the meantime
we continue to see
joe biden's approval rating go up
and republicans are furious many of them
are leaving me voicemails which i'm not
going to play because they're just very
lame but republicans are now saying
biden is as unpopular as ever when of
course the truth is joe biden has seen
one of the most
rapid
increases in approval rating uh of any
president in recent years now he's still
only at about 43 percent and
it's sort of a glass half full glass
half empty sort of thing you can say
well 43 means 15 57 still disapprove but
you can also look at the last several
presidencies and realize that actually
43
it's no incredible victory but it's
pretty average in terms of where many
presidents tend to be during their
presidency so taking a look at the
numbers now on the screen
you see that joe biden had this sort of
bottom out at 37 and a half percent now
remember 538 is looking at an average of
approval polls so
it's an it's it's based on more than one
poll these are averages
the approval bottomed out at 37.5
in the second half of july and it's been
a basically direct increase now to about
43 so that's roughly an increase of 15
in joe biden's approval rating and i
have to tell you it sort of makes sense
in that
lots of good things have taken place
many of them associated with joe biden
there's this crew
it's almost quaint sounding
that a president does a bunch of stuff
people like and then their approval
rating goes up because we're so used to
this
highly partisan
almost weaponized
approval rating situation where approval
is
more related to propaganda rather than
accomplishments but we now have two jobs
reports in a row that are better than
expectations under the biden
administration
we have inflation down last month we are
days away from the next inflation number
and my expectation is that it's going to
be down again significant legislative
accomplishments infrastructure the pact
act the inflation reduction act student
loan forgiveness which is very popular
with americans and it's reflected now in
the approval rating and there's other
things as well gas prices also are
continuing to experience one of the most
sustained and rapid declines
in a very very long time
and
average gas prices peaked at five
dollars and two cents in mid-june and it
has been declined decline decline
initially very rapid then a little bit
less rapid but continuing down gas
prices are now down to 373 from 502 a
gallon that is a 25-ish
percent 26 percent decline
that is more than a quarter chopped off
of gas prices everybody's gas bill down
by a quarter
this is a big big deal i don't even
claim it has anything to do with joe
biden i didn't believe biden was
responsible for the gas prices going up
and i don't believe joe biden is
responsible for the gas prices going
down aside from a few cents a gallon
because of he of tapping the strategic
petroleum reserve but i'm consistent
i don't play the gas price games with
presidents
but we know
that that's something many people do
look at when answering the question do
you approve the job of the job that the
president is doing so we'll have new
inflation data next week i expect that
it will be
again a decline in uh in inflation and
joe biden's approval rating reflecting
what is overall
a pretty damn good economy by all
standard metrics
and now the question becomes what does
it do
to democratic chances in the fall
and the numbers continue to improve a
little bit at a time a little bit at a
time we will delve into those numbers in
more detail tomorrow
we are now asking a question that a year
ago i would not have been asking and
that question is has cnn decided to
become fox news
what
david what are you talking about sir
please explain
well this all started
as a result of the
new ceo of cnn
or or president i guess they call him
chris licht has been selected as the
next president of cnn we learned this in
february of 2022 and immediately after
this was the case and we learned about
this
we started to learn about chris licht we
learned that he created morning joe he
revamped cbs this morning he revitalized
this is cnn's own words he revitalized
the late show with stephen colbert
and um he was selected back in february
to take control of cnn
one of the statements one of the big
headlines very quickly became
cnn management is intent
on changing perception of the network
that's from abc news
uh just a few days ago or a couple weeks
ago
and
as we have started to see
a number of resignations from cnn
licht reportedly told cnn staffers don't
call the big lie the big lie anymore
saying that sounds like a democratic
slogan so trump's attempt to steal the
election that he didn't win
don't call it the big lie anymore and we
have started to see some walkouts from
some relatively high profile
correspondents at cnn john harwood
brian stelter jeffrey toobin john cooper
tweeted
i decided to boycott cnn as soon as the
network began its shift to the right it
was a tough decision since i've been a
devout cnn viewer since i was in my 20s
if i wanted to watch right wing
propaganda i'd watch fox so for now it's
only msnbc for me
cnn anchor brianna keeler took some heat
when she tweeted
after joe biden's thursday speech last
week which we covered quote whatever you
think of this speech the military is
supposed to be a political positioning
marines in uniform behind president
biden for a political speech flies in
the face of that it's wrong when
democrats do it it's wrong with
republicans do it well trump did it too
presidents do it and you don't always
hear the same criticism in fact here's a
picture of trump from 2019 doing the
exact same thing now okay bry brianna
keeler says she's against it in all
cases but they didn't really talk about
it that i was able to find in 2019 so
this was another
little data point
in some of our viewers and others saying
there just is a shift in feel about
what's going on at cnn
recently cnn also made the decision to
hire a guy named john miller
john miller top intel official
award-winning journalist and
best-selling author writes cnn
added to the network's roster of expert
analysts added as a chief law
enforcement and intelligence analyst
well miller is a guy who lied under oath
about nypd policy of surveilling muslims
in the post-9 11 era it's kind of absurd
to say
we are hiring this guy as a law
enforcement analyst so a number of
different red flags increasingly raising
questions about what is happening here
at cnn and i want to remind people of
the most important aspect to all of this
you know for so long there's these
phrases that people just repeat repeat
repeat fox is left and cnn and msnbc are
on the right
and as i've reminded people many times
before
uh fox is on the right i'm sorry did i
say that backwards fox is on the right
cnn and msnbc are on the left i'm now
thinking i might have gotten that wrong
before what i meant to say in case i
didn't is fox is on the right
cnn msnbc are on the left and as i've
said before
fox is on the right
in a completely unhinged propagandistic
way
msnbc editorially has taken a
center-left perspective it's a
democratic party perspective it's not
progressive and cnn
plays it closer to the middle while
certainly having an anti-trump bias i
think that's perfectly fine but
fundamentally these are all
corporate media outlets with profit as
their primary goal
and that should not
it should then not surprise us
when a change in leadership at cnn
potentially signals a significant
editorial shift as well because these
organizations fundamentally
are there to make money that's what
they're there for and you know we've
been accused of the same oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad but of course that's
really kind of a joke right i mean we're
funded directly by our audience
because we are a progressive show these
corporate media outlets are much more
similar than they are different even if
the type of propaganda you see is not
the same so at the end of the day
it's not a major shock that if cnn
perceives it can make more money by
having higher ratings by making this
shift in the direction of the right that
they would do it we'll see in the next
few months and particularly in their
coverage of the 2022 midterms how it all
shakes out
remember on september 19th
we are doing a massive
membership discount if you'd like to be
notified about this discount just get on
my newsletter at davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is ketoned we
all have heard about the ketogenic diet
which puts your body in a metabolic
state of ketosis many have reported that
it's helpful for curbing hunger or even
weight loss
ketoned is the top rated ketone
supplement on the market it allows you
to enjoy the benefits without
dramatically restricting your carbs and
if you already follow a ketogenic diet
ketoned is a great way to instantly
boost your ketone levels their formula
works in under 20 minutes take ketoned
advanced blend and then test your ketone
levels and see for yourself comes in
delicious flavors like aloha punch
tiger's blood citrus mango peach and
caramel macchiato or caramel macchiato
or caramel macchiato
ketone has helped millions of people on
their keto journey since 2016. read
online what ketone customers have to say
and ketoned is giving my audience thirty
percent off plus two free bottles of
keto charged when you go to
ketoned.com
pacman and use the code pacman at
checkout
we have now learned that indeed failed
former president donald trump had
documents with nuclear secrets on them
at his house at mar-a-lago and the
immediate question becomes
what the hell was he planning to do with
those was he planning to sell them did
he sell them and of course all sorts of
speculation running rampant so let's go
back and start at the top it was
speculated that there might have been
uh documents relating to nuclear
capabilities at donald trump's
mar-a-lago
part of
the search warrant served by the fbi at
his home we now have gotten confirmation
of that from the washington post's
devlin barrett and carol lenig
a document describing a foreign
government's military defenses including
nuclear capabilities
was found
by fbi agents who searched former
president donald trump's mar-a-lago
residents and private club last month
according to people familiar with the
matter
underscoring concerns among u.s
intelligence officials about classified
materials stashed in the florida
property
some of the seas documents detail top
secret u.s operations
so closely guarded that many senior
national security officials are kept in
the dark about them only the president
some members of his cabinet or a near
cabinet-level official could authorize
other government officials to know
details of these special access programs
documents about such highly classified
operations require special clearances on
a need to know basis not just a top
secret stop top secret clearance some
special access programs can have as few
as a couple dozen government personnel
authorized to know about the operation's
existence
records that deal with such programs are
kept under lock and key
almost always in a secure
compartmented information facility with
a designated control officer to keep
careful tabs on their location
these documents sometimes require
the constant
surveillance of the documents to know
exactly where they are at all times
and trump had him at his house
trump had him at his house
this is getting worse every single day
now the timing of this release i believe
and many do as well i'm not unique in
this belief i didn't come up with this
that the timing is related to the
appointment of a special master
to oversee the documents that even
trump's own former attorney general
william barr thinks is inappropriate and
is a decision that will ultimately be
reversed
and i do believe the timing is in order
to counteract that and to sort of say
all right well you figure out a way to
delay things but more and more
information is going to come out now why
would trump
who has a lot of debt
relied on a lot of foreign money to
become president
why would trump keep documents about the
nuclear capabilities of other countries
at his house
do you think trump is aware that many
adversaries of the united states would
be willing to pay
for those documents is trump aware that
many adversaries of the united states
would love to try to steal certain
documents do we still believe that there
is a perfectly innocent explanation for
this
i don't
i don't and i'm starting to think maybe
it's not true that trump wanted these
documents so that he could write his
memoirs or so that they could be in his
presidential library which by all
accounts he doesn't even care about now
here is trump's lawyer one of trump's
lawyers alina habba just yesterday
mocking the idea that the stolen
documents included nuclear secrets this
was yesterday i saw this meme that was
very funny
on instagram i believe it was and it
said it's amazing at first it was the
codes to the nuclear weapons
now it's invisible classified documents
so she's mocking the idea
that there were nuclear related
documents there
and yet there are and yet there are
uh you really have to wonder
what else has trump done
over the last
four five six years
that we haven't even learned about yet
and as i've said before i believed it
would take years to learn the full scope
of what he did and it's taking years
it's taking years and um
this is all
you know there's a couple different
possibilities here as i said about the
timing
one possibility is this is the intel
community
fighting back or signaling back about
the special master decision saying you
know you can put in place a special
master
but we can keep releasing more and more
every day
about the damaging reality of what
donald trump did
the other possibility here is that the
special master
obviously the intent of that by trump is
to just slow down what's going on maybe
particularly in the context of the
midterms and the intel community here is
saying we can accelerate the release of
this information now i can't believe i'm
actually saying this
but this is potentially treasonous what
donald trump has done if you look at a
couple of different statutes 18 us code
subsection 794
is called gathering or delivering
defense information to aid foreign
government
okay
we're talking about crimes there
and uh
check google the statute and read it for
yourself it's quite lengthy another
possibility 18 us code 793 gathering
transmitting or losing defense
information
also a crime this is
extraordinarily serious and of course
listen at every step we knew it was
serious when we learned about the
investigations we knew it was serious
when the fbi decided to do the raid we
knew it was serious
when trump
and his cronies started throwing absurd
conflicting explanations at the wall to
see what sticks we knew it was very
serious and now that this has been found
we know it is even more serious and
unfortunately for trump his lawyers are
rapidly deteriorating when confronted
about these issues
so let's now review some of these clips
of trump lawyer alina habba
um
asked about
the documents and the empty folders mark
top secret and all of it so as a
reminder one of the things we learned
last week was that among the documents
recovered by the fbi from trump's house
there were also empty folders marked top
secret now obviously if you see an empty
mold folder marked top secret you say
well where's the document that was in it
it's extraordinarily unlikely that
donald trump took empty folders so
there's probably more documents
somewhere
trump attorney alina habba was asked
about this and she started joking about
memes and invisible documents check this
out obviously and then the other thing
too that we we can't get past is that
these envelopes most of them were empty
what is that i don't know i saw this
meme that was very funny um on instagram
i believe it was and notice that she
says i don't know what it means and
quickly switches to talking about memes
that it's amazing at first it was the
codes to the nuclear weapons
now it's invisible classified documents
um you know it could mean anything i
don't know it could mean that they gave
those documents to nara and to the fbi
prior as we know which they had done now
think about that this is the best
now she gives explanations that make no
sense her first claim is maybe the fault
the top secret folders were empty
because trump returned the documents
you're saying he would return the
documents and not the folder that
doesn't make any sense whatsoever so
that one's not believable um it could
mean there was nothing in them
there was nothing in them so there was
nothing in them also doesn't make sense
because trump's legal team and trump
himself have insisted
that the documents there were documents
that they shouldn't be able to be
reviewed as evidenced by the department
of justice so if there were no documents
why would trump be arguing
that the documents shouldn't be
be reviewed by the fbi if there were no
documents he would say there were no
documents it could mean they're
invisible if you're you know in their
administration i truly don't know you
know okay there might there might be
invisible documents so as as always
the explanations contradict
maybe there were never any documents in
there then why did trump's legal team
build a defense based on the fact that
there were documents there that doesn't
make any sense maybe he returned the
documents
but he kept the folders that doesn't
make any sense either it only creates
more questions and by the way just a
really funny
extra note from this interview
she did try to pivot to hunter biden i
it's beyond parody at this point but she
tried meanwhile we have hunter biden who
has you know the laptop from hell
nothing's happening there i don't even
see
the laptop from hell
and it just won't be investigated by
anybody so the trump legal team at odds
with itself about what is going on and
what we are very rapidly learning is
this is very very bad make sure you're
following us on instagram at david
pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
tim miller who's a writer and political
consultant the author of why we did it a
travelogue from the republican road to
hell and his show is also available on
snapchat and is called not my party tim
great having you on i really appreciate
it david i've seen you on the uh
youtube's been feeding you to me so oh
that's good that's shot to me usually
right-wing stuff is fed to left-wingers
but i like to see the opposite happening
a little bit so i mean okay just to kind
of um
like orient our audience sure you are
not on the trump train for lack of a
better term but i think it would be
interesting to hear about
when did you start to think that the
republican party was going in a
direction that you didn't like that
didn't make sense to your values yeah
well this is uh you're hitting at the
regrets part of the book the why we did
it we is an important word there because
i'm included in we even though i i
bailed on trump uh the minute he went
down that escalator bailed on on the
idea that i would support him but as i
look back on it one of my first jobs in
politics is i was the iowa spokesperson
for john mccain during the 2008 primary
uh and so uh i was obviously the lead
off kickoff the caucus states was a very
important kind of role i was excited
about the role and
uh the types of people that were showing
up to the john mccain uh uh town halls
that we would have and the kind of
questions that he was getting over and
over about their concerns about the
invasion at the southern border and you
know globalists and the nafta super
highway this was a conspiracy theory
back at the time that never came to pass
i don't know if you noticed we never did
get that nafta superhighway but right
these folks would come and and i started
to get get a sense that oh man like
maybe the like the people that make up
this party you know have a set of values
that are separate from mine then
obviously mccain goes on to take pick
sarah palin palin uh the rallies the
palin rallies were were very much a
proto
example of these trump rallies right of
of people shouting about barack hussein
obama and being a muslim
and so you know i i kind of rationalized
that and justified it because i still
like john mccain and still
believed in his political program which
was quite different than donald trump's
political program and i was ambitious
you know and wanted to continue to be
successful in my career and so i think
that using a few different
rationalizations i kind of blocked out
the fact that i in retrospect i really
saw this all coming in 2007. yeah and
what's interesting about that is there's
this viral moment where at some event i
don't remember where it was this woman
asks john mccain uh you know i or not
even really asked just sort of says like
i think obama's a muslim and mccain says
no he's not he's an american and he's
just someone with whom i have political
differences so that was sort of the type
of signal you're talking about here
for sure and and it helped me justify
staying along with john mccain right
there is a like sometimes people on the
left would be like the party was always
corrupted it was always racist was
always horrible and it's like well there
were elements that that is true right
but but also leadership does matter and
having somebody at the top of the ticket
who would say no ma'am that is not true
having someone at the top of the ticket
during mccain's concession speech he was
graceful he was getting booed when he
said we all need to unite behind our new
president and give us our support he
gets booed by the crowd so you can see
this tension right between somebody
who's trying to be a leader and a
statesman who has some conservative
values
and a reactionary political base that's
looking for someone to feed their
grievance um the base got what they
wanted uh you know about eight years
later so
what
were the issues
that to you are the important political
issues that that make you or made you a
republican like is it is it taxation is
it regulation what what is it
yeah i hate to be a cliche but i was
always one of these people who was kind
of socially liberal um uh you know
though i
the word pro-life is is getting uh
mangled these days what does that mean
like uh you know i believe there should
be some some restrictions on abortion i
don't know my abortion position might be
closer to bill clinton in 1992 than the
current pro-life position but but any
but besides that i was pretty socially
liberal and yeah i i think the
government uh a lot of times gets in the
way of uh of economic growth of
prosperity in our society i'm obviously
a capitalist i think that america is a
force uh can play a force for good in
the world um you know i think this is
frankly more of a joe biden point of
view these days than it is a donald
trump point of view but you know i do
believe and and american you know power
and influence over
overseas uh and you know i i believe
that america was a shining city on the
hill where we should be welcoming people
from throughout the world and and that
they can have their opportunity to take
the blessings of the of the country
right like for that was like a core
republican view as i was growing up
right in the 80s and 90s right
reagan and bush were very liberal on
immigration and you know they spoke to
american greatness and believing in the
american experiment a lot of times i
look at the left and say oh they're down
talking america you know they want to
change what is good about the country
and so that is kind of what had me
falling on the republican side despite
the fact that i obviously had
disagreements with parts of the nativist
wing of the party on immigration i'm gay
we haven't talked about that obviously
on gay marriage and those issues i
disagreed and and i came to disagree
with the more extreme
you know views even on economic issues
that were you know uh that the tea party
you know and the you know shutting down
the government you know we can never
raise taxes on on anyone making over 400
000 right some of these extreme economic
views i i've sort of come around to the
center on
so
it seems clear that now there are lots
of folks who are
sincerely trump supporters and then
there are some folks on the republican
side who are overtly anti-trump and then
there's sort of like the suspicion which
i think we've we've learned is is true
that there are people who are kind of
publicly trump supporters but really
privately they are not can you talk
about like early when it became clear
trump was becoming the nominee what was
your experience of those kind of three
groups and maybe the third one is really
the most interesting the ones who
publicly are still defending him but but
pub pro pub privately rather did not
like him yeah the third group i think is
the most interesting group and that's
who the book focuses on right i don't i
sort of hated all the never trumper
books that like wanted to make us seem
like the heroes like to me i don't i
didn't think we were heroes trump was
manifestly unfit and corrupt and
dangerous and racist but it's like i i
did the obvious thing in my opinion uh
the genuine trump supporters i think
there's an interesting book to be
written about them right i think this is
a real streak within our country right
now i saw that up close we talked about
it these iowa events people who are
genuinely nativists uh genuine
protectionist i want to change kind of
this uh the way that uh you know the
post-world war ii kind of american you
know set up set up of america's role in
the world um the third group though is
one who agrees with me on everything but
but basically wanted to continue on with
their political career or maybe they
don't agree with me on everything right
i think that the liz cheney at least
stefanik is a good example of this right
liz cheney is far more conservative than
me
on social issues on foreign policy even
at least stephanie and i work together
she's one of the chapters in the book
she and i were rhino squish moderate
republicans right she believes climate
change is real she believes in gay
marriage she you know wanted a liberal
immigration policy uh but you know she
also believed in lower taxes and a
strong america overseas well elise
stefanik is now the one who is rising
within the party and not liz cheney
because she is willing to go along with
the cult and go write the lies unless
cheney wants them so so in that third
group you know what shocked me it did
not shock me that trump took over the
party i like i said in 07 i got a hint
that something like this could happen um
it did not what shocked me was just to a
person how almost everyone i had worked
with ended up going along with it and i
would have these dinners and these
breakfasts these tortured drinks where
people would explain oh you know all of
their rationales
and so what i tried to explore in the
book is
all these different rationales the ones
that are ridiculous the ones that are
mockable the ones that are kind of in
the ballpark of defensible um uh
and try to adjudicate how it was that
these people i think who are the central
villains essentially of the book and of
our time um uh came to decide to do what
they did because trump couldn't have
gotten power just with the true
believers right like there aren't enough
of them he had to win over that third
group right
who strikes you as a sort of uh faking
it type republican right now of the
people that are kind of in the public
eye defending trump
um well most of them uh kevin mccarthy
and elise obvi i i guess i just talked
about elise but kevin kevin mccarthy uh
you know i saw i i write in the book
about lindsey graham you know lindsey
graham and i he supported jed i was
jeb's communications director we spent a
lot of time together um you know he
would call me all the time ranting about
donald trump how much he hated him like
one night i couldn't get away from him
because he was drinking all the
chardonnay ranting about how trump is a
racist and a bigot so is he faking it
now or i don't know if faking it is
right word i think that he's come around
to believing that the thing that he
cares about the most is access to power
and and that he can deal with trump's
flaws in exchange for what he thinks
he's getting which is influence access
to powers i don't know if he's faking it
so much as he's just his calculation has
changed uh but i think most of the
political strategists in the class uh
which is which is what i talk about are
you know at some level
you know not
it would would be if they all let's just
put it this way
pretty much everybody in the
establishment wing in the republican
party if they could snap their fingers
and have a magic genie appear and say
donald trump is just going to disappear
from the face of the planet and ron
desantis is going to take over the party
they all would snap their fingers in a
second oh well so let me talk about that
yeah that was going to be my next
question in terms of like what's the
path out of this because the interesting
thing about you mentioning desantis is
when i think about john mccain and mitt
romney
desantis seems way more like trump than
like any of them so i'm kind of
interested in
the path out of this trumpist nightmare
on the republican side does it have to
be someone like desantis who i almost
see as like a slightly less incompetent
version of trump but close to as
dangerous is that just by necessity what
it has to be or is there a way to get
back to someone like a mitt romney who
seems so comparatively benign right now
yeah there's no path back to the benign
i mean at least in the short term um
here's the thing and
donald trump gave these the people this
is a bottom-up problem not a top-down
problem and the book is about people's
moral
sacrifices right and how they went along
with somebody that they that was
clownishly corrupt right yeah um just
for their own power so so that part you
know
they're complicit they but but but what
is the core issue here is that is that
what voters want
is someone that's going to channel their
grievance and their rage and their hate
for the left for elites for the media
for you know whatever uh people who are
expressing their gender identity in
different ways like their hatred for
whoever that is they want someone to
channel that that's what they care about
not policies right this is the
difference between the dem base and the
republican base like there may be some
people on the dem base who have extreme
views but they have actual policies that
they want to see enacted the republican
base just want somebody to channel their
grievance and so okay if that's what
these voters want they're never gonna
they're not turning back to anyone like
mitt romney after donald trump gave them
what they could have like for a while
they're like oh i'll hold my nose for
john mccain because this is the best we
can do we need somebody like this to win
now they have come to realize no we can
win with someone that that shares our
cruelty and our hatred and so why would
we go back to mitt romney right like
they never would and so no i i think
that there's a possible chance for
somebody who is a like a boris johnson
type i wouldn't call that benign i think
that is our best hope right somebody who
can fake the grievance stuff you know
and throw people a little bit of red
meat you know with some cultural
um
resentments which boris was good at but
but like on the policy side of things is
like was basically you know kind of like
a center-right nationalist you know not
not exactly the kind of person i would
want not like a classically liberal
conservative but i i think it's possible
that someone like that could appear but
no the desantis mold is is the way the
party is going for sure or or maybe even
worse honestly maybe even tucker or
something to that effect well
in looking at some of these recent trump
rallies and cpac
what gets the most applause
is the overtly homophobic and
transphobic stuff like in watching cpac
the crowd was kind of dead
until ted cruz ridiculed pronouns and i
don't remember who it was talked about
trans women in sports like the the
applause lines were the homophobic
transphobic applause trump now tells the
story about the weight lifting
and the swimmer you know it's the it's
these every single rally it's the same
stories is that surprising to see that
kind of resurface
i wouldn't say so it's disappointing
because look we all play these games
like in my head
i i felt like the gay rights
march was going forward and we those of
us on the pro gay rights side were
winning and so
you know i that it wasn't
you know by the time i really came into
politics like the writing was on the
wall right like the march for to
progress was marching forward and thank
thank you to all the people that did
that fight before we got there but but
i should have see we should have known
that there would be backsliding right
the types these people their hatreds
their cruelty they didn't go away you
know a lot of times the republicans get
caricatured as like being so stupid that
they don't know what they're doing
they're they're strategic they're
tactical if you listen to focus groups
or republican voters that they didn't
change their mind on gay marriage
they're just like well this is a loser
for us right like it's not worth
fighting it right now right it's a
political loser we're going to go win on
other issues that's why they moved on to
the trans stuff right
now with the with what desantis is doing
in the schools with don't say gay the
pronouns the tran the transports they're
they're emboldened again they're like
wait a minute no this can be a winner we
can bring the our our um
you know we can otherize them and attack
them and that can be a political winner
for us again so we're going to do that
and so i so you know while i think the
good natured side of me was hoping that
this stuff was passed i don't think it
should be surprising because it's not
like these people died they're all still
here all the people that still did you
know that were for anti-gay marriage
initiatives in 2004 uh most of them are
still around right so um uh you know
it's not it's not as if all their views
changed they just made a political
calculation so the snapchat show not my
party i don't even understand snapchat
like i'm on tick tock tick tock i get
and we're doing well on tech talk
my sister is on snapchat she says it's
it's really like the hub for people who
are a little bit younger than me
how did this develop well basically so
snapchat had these shows and it's mostly
for 13 to 24 year olds right who are on
it essentially and and they had like ben
shapiro you know and they had like super
left stuff maybe like you're you're not
on there but some of your competitors
out there in the left space right the
actual socialists not like
yeah the actual social so the snapchat
folks came to me like we need like
somebody in the middle like we besides
charlie kirk and you know aoc right like
we need to serve this audience because
there are a lot of teams that are still
kind of working their way through their
political identity and so i try to offer
a show once a week post on thursdays on
snapchat it's just four minutes it's fun
it's fast and it's like hey here's a
look at the news and here's a look at
what's happening in politics we talked
about the student loan thing
and and i don't i hate to say balanced
because i'm not trying to do this fake
centrist oh on the one hand on the other
hand thing but it's like we're heterodox
right like i don't every once in a while
i still agree with the republican on
something right but we're i'm not maga
you know i'm not going to tell you
exactly what you want to hear every week
and so i hear a lot from kids in college
who who appreciate the show because
they're like man on campus everyone is
either
you know in the k f in the k hive or a
social justice warrior or a mega and i
don't fit that and i think that a lot of
people feel that way and so they're
trying to navigate through their views
and so i think that the fact that i've
been
cast out from the republican party it
gives me a chance to have the freedom to
just kind of tell people and give people
an honest look at what's happening well
uh i got to get on that snapchat i've
got to figure out what's going on on
there your show would do well i should
really sample some some clips on there
it's an interesting idea actually um
tim's show is not my party on snapchat
the book is why we did it a travelogue
from the republican road to hell we've
been speaking with tim miller tim thank
you so much david thanks brother
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow this is one of my
favorite stories of the year it's up
there when with when alex jones attacked
me
my pillow ceo mike lindell also known to
many of us as mike pillow or simply
pillow
spent hours on our facebook page
attacking me in comments
and arguing with many of you
viewers wrote to me
and said david pillow is in the comments
on your youtube channel and he's
attacking you and he's attacking us and
he's calling people bots you have to see
this and i said wait
pillow is worth 300 million dollars he's
running a pillow business which now
sells coffee and it sells slippers and
bathrobes and all there's no way
that this guy is in my facebook comments
attacking me and my viewers is there
and indeed there is
we you might remember i interviewed this
republican candidate mark
mike cargile not long ago
and he said that there's satanic people
and there's machines that are bad
elections and all this different stuff
and guys completely unhinged and a lot
of the stuff mike pillow agrees with
check out these comments and again this
is a full-grown man worth 300 million
dollars and this is how he is spending
hours mike lindell yes david i believe
you need prayer well thanks mike i
appreciate your concern
uh
mike pillow showing up and saying i
posted evidence of the voter fraud we
have to get rid of the machines over 54
countries have now been taken by the
machines
uh yeah
mike pillow continuing
um and attacking people and attacking
machine saying we need to get rid of the
voting machines california has 2.8
million more people on their voter rolls
than people that can vote of course
that's completely untrue there is no
place
no state that has more voters than more
people registered than actual legal
voters doesn't exist then mike lindell
started calling people bots he called
julia bot
he called blaken
a paid bot he said to norm we need to
get rid of the voting machines and
computers running our elections we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines he called susie a paid bot
he said to me david why don't you check
out the evidence
well i would love to when i interviewed
him i told him to send me the evidence
after his symposium
he never did
mike cargile said he would send me the
evidence he never did
mike focusing in on a guy named jay and
said i just posted evidence in this feed
we have to get rid of the machines i see
you are a paid bot what a shame
mike lindell said to nancy so sad you
are a paid bot
he called tanya a paid bot he called
john another paid bot
he said that pisa
is a paid bot
uh he said chris is a paid bot
he said ruth is a paid bot he called
otto a paid bot
and to stu ray he called him a bot with
two t's which i have to tell you i've
never that's like a double bot of some
kind
then mike pillow guys remember this is
an adult
worth 300 million dollars
he started posting a link to some kind
of frank speech interview with a guy
named clint curtis who again is one of
these whistleblowers who presents no
evidence whatsoever
he then posted a link about p caps
and dennis montgomery which doesn't
actually provide any evidence of any
voter fraud whatsoever he then posted a
link to his moment of truth summit which
no one watched and then maybe most
importantly pillow saying david why
don't you have me
on your horrible show
to which i say pillow you're welcome
anytime sir he's been on before i asked
him for the evidence he didn't send it
he now seems to be saying he's willing
to be back on
we are trying to get him back on and
maybe now he will give me the evidence
um just a couple other posts he then
posted a link to some video called
inside the machines over 54 countries
have now been taken by the machines
posting over a period of multiple hours
posting that link many many times
isn't this the strangest thing that
we've ever seen happen like when alex
jones attacked me thank your lucky stars
every day you're not dave pacman yeah
that is a freaking predator right there
right when alex jones attacked me
he did it on his own show right so he
did it for content he got something out
of it maybe at the end of his attack on
me alex jones sold you know some kind of
uh supplement or something like that
pillow is just mixing it up in the
youtube in the facebook comments with
our own viewers
i don't see what he could possibly have
to gain from this he really this makes
me think he's a true believer let me put
it that way so there it is and we
welcome pillow back on the program
absolutely any time and hopefully
that'll be soon
the next layer in the fake elector scam
is now pushing towards criminality
you have to see this this is
unbelievable
newly obtained surveillance video
shows fake trump elector
escorted operatives
into georgia county's elections office
before
the voting machine breach
let's reset the story
the fake elector scam the fake elector
scam was where there were states won by
joe biden in november of 2020 yes nearly
two years ago they're still going nearly
two years ago in november of 2020 joe
biden won certain states like georgia
and arizona and republicans came up with
the idea
of just sending different electors
to say we cast our ballot we cast our
electoral votes
for donald trump even though trump
didn't win they would claim that he did
we now have footage of a republican and
a republican county official in georgia
who was one of these fake electors
escorting two operatives
working with an attorney for trump
into the county's election offices
on the same day that a voting system
there was breached
understand that these people
breached election systems okay
in the surveillance video
obtained by cnn
kathy latham a former republican
chairwoman of coffee county under
criminal investigation for posing as a
fake elector in 2020
escorted a team of pro-trump
operatives to the election offices on
january 7 2021
that's the same day
that the voting system there was
breached
they are the ones breaching the systems
they are the ones attempting the fraud
here is a report from cnn newly obtained
video to cnn shows a former georgia
republican county official escorting two
operatives hired by an attorney for
former president trump
into the county's election offices on
the same day a voting system there was
illegally breached wow drew griffin has
the details drew what an incredible
coincidence right breaches of these
voting machines guys and swing states
are under investigation across the
country this one happened in coffee
county georgia rural county cnn obtained
surveillance video at one of the offices
where the voting machines were breached
and all this at the best of one of
donald trump's attorneys i want to show
you right now this is kathy latham we're
showing you she's the former chairwoman
of coffee county gop
already under investigation this woman
is for posing as one of those fake
electors who signed documents that
declared donald trump was the winner of
the 2020 election latham can be seen
here escorting a team of pro-trump
operatives into the coffee county
elections office including an i.t
specialist who was working with trump
attorney sydney powell this all happens
on the same day the vote can you imagine
they have so many conspiracy theories
they were the ones conspiring look at
this voting system in that office was
illegally breached january 7 2021 the
day after the attack on the u.s capitol
text messages emails and witness
testimony from a civil lawsuit against
georgia election officials have
connected latham that woman to the plan
to give the group access to the
election's office
about a week before this voting machine
breach that same woman latham testified
before the georgia state legislature
along with rudy giuliani talking all
about voter machine irregularities in
coffee county latham's attorney told cnn
seems some of the irregularities were
latham herself giving people who
shouldn't have access to the voting
systems access to the voting systems is
anybody ever going to jail for trying to
steal the 2020 election for trump while
they were screaming election fraud
mail in ballot fraud democratic fraud
for months
they tried to steal it they did it in
this particular case in broad daylight
daylight if you didn't see the video
it's the middle of the day when they
show up
and i'm sure that some of them would say
we had to do this stuff because the
democrats cheated
the democrats were cheating so bad that
we had to do it this way
but
you all in my audience
didn't fall for it when trump started
with this stuff late spring early summer
2020.
when trump started saying they're going
to rig it this way they're going to rig
it that way it's all insecure
many of you dozens and dozens of you
wrote to me and said david allegations
or confessions with these people
trump's saying he's going to try to
steal it that's what trump is saying and
of course you were all completely
correct
incredible
people better start landing in prison
for this they really should and we're
going to follow that and as charges
develop
and hopefully they will
we will tell you whether people are
actually being held accountable
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
many of you might have heard about
trump derangement syndrome well a caller
called in
who believes that there is biden
derangement syndrome going on down in
texas where he lives take a listen to
this
hi david this is chris down in texas
yeah and uh
i notice in my account i see
s biden bumper stickers f biden
stickers on the gas pumps oh yeah signs
in yards and it seems like there's a lot
of biden derangement syndrome down here
i would say doesn't really get talked
about
and then uh
thinking about barack obama how they
were so obsessed with what suit he wore
and uh the birtherism seems like there's
been a lot of derangement syndrome
on their side for quite a long time of
course there has and they just love to
say oh trump derangement syndrome you
know i was not not long ago i was in
um
well i guess i don't know if it's
considered upstate new york or not i
know that you know in the city what's
considered upstate is different but in
the hudson valley area and hudson new
york itself is quite liberal and it's
become kind of like a you know a place
where people from the city uh drive up
and hang out for the weekend great
restaurants and uh you know furniture
shops and all of it but in the small
towns surrounding hudson as we were
driving in
there were a shocking number of places
selling biden paraphernalia antibiotic i
should say you know fjb
let's go brandon weird like voodoo type
dolls of joe biden and stuff like that
so if that's going on in new york state
and i know that the further you get from
the city the more right-wing new york
new york state gets but
i can only imagine what's going on in
texas and yes there is quite a bit of
derangement on today's bonus show we are
going to talk about the new uk prime
minister liz truss
it's happening it has happened and what
happens now
with the relationship with the united
states a new mexico official has been
ousted for participating in the january
sixth insurrection that's good news
we'll tell you the details and senator
ted cruz one of the most disgusting
members of the u.s senate wants to block
student loan forgiveness what's the
argument well we'll tell you on the
bonus show all of those stories and more
when producer pat joins me on the bonus
show you can sign up today at
joinpacman.com if you're waiting for
that sweet sweet discount for a
membership get on my newsletter because
on september 19th 9 19 we are doing a 19
themed membership special it's going to
be nuts our lawyer
accountant
and entire staff is begging me with
tears in their eyes david sir
don't do this discount
but i am committed to doing it and you
can be notified on september 19th of
this great opportunity to become a
member
simply by getting on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com i'll see you on the
bonus show today if you are already a
member otherwise we'll be back tomorrow
with a brand new